milord winning actor that's Kevin Bacon
has created a social media campaign to
encourage social distancing celebrities
like Ellen DeGeneres Demi Lovato Elton
John have all participated in the I stay
home for challenge Kevin Bacon kicked it
off by sharing who he stays home for
right now like people around the world
I'm staying home because it saves lives
and it is the only way we're gonna slow
down the spread of this coronavirus
every one of us has someone who is worth
staying home for and I am staying home
for kyra sedgwick and Kyra Sedgwick is a
doll and Kevin's wife we were on a plane
once she's awesome Kevin Bacon is with
us now from his home in Los Angeles good
morning to you Kevin Bacon we've all
played that six degrees of separation
game with Kevin Bacon but you're taking
it to a whole different level so Bravo
and thank you what made you come up with
this what were you seeing that you
thought well hold on people well you
know I've always felt that six degrees
was was a cool concept if you take me
out of it you know I don't think it's
ever really been about about me it's
really about the connectivity of people
on this on this planet and it's really
about our desire to feel connected to
somebody else so those two things are
happening so simultaneously it's such a
real and kind of terrifying way right
now and so I felt like it to play off of
that and to try to encourage people to
social distance and to think about the
fact that somebody that they interact
with is going to interact with somebody
else today I interact with somebody else
and that and that that interaction could
cause somebody to become sick and and
everybody is going to I think we're
already at the point where everybody
feels like they know somebody or
or somebody knows somebody who's who's
gotten sick or who is at risk and so
this just seemed like a natural fit yeah
and you've heard from thousands of
people who have responded to the I stay
at home for hashtag I mean are there any
messages that stand out to you there's
so many well that's a great thing about
a hashtag is that I'm incredibly
grateful for the celebrity component and
there's that there's a lot of them then
and and they've done a lot of fun stuff
and interesting stuff and it's it's it's
kind of spread in that way in it which
is really a lot of fun but also just
regular people I get to look at their
hashtags and I mean I won one guy really
cracking me up because he he's 97 and
you just he just has his sign up and
says I stay home from me and I you know
i I've been so impressed but you know
the kids and people from all over the
world and the other important thing that
I want to point out is that you know
there's a lot of people that can't stay
home because they are on the front lines
the heroes of this of this situation you
know our medical workers and our first
responders and and even the unlikely
heroes that we have out there working in
grocery stores and sanitation and all
all these things so if nothing else
let's stay home for them to try to keep
them as as healthy as possible because
we really need them right now I know I
so I I feel go ahead no you go ahead
finish go ahead
I just feel really I feel really
grateful that I have a situation where I
can be here I do have enough food and
there and I I you know and with my wife
and my and and that I feel extremely
grateful for all of those things we just
have to keep our in in our minds the
people that are not so fortunate I'm so
glad that you started this game our
co-anchor Anthony Mason is at home he's
taking your challenge - hey Anthony do
you have anything for Kevin he can see
he can hear you yeah I wanted to ask one
of the this staying home thing is very
interesting because
the abstract everybody loves the idea
and then but we're not used to spending
as this much time with each other even
the people we really love it I know
Kevin you've been married I think for
what thirty years to Kira are you
finding any challenges that you're
actually spending more time together now
yeah we're doing okay I think I think
the marriage is gonna survive the virus
yeah I mean we're doing we're doing
we're doing well we we really enjoy each
other's company and again we're like
super super grateful for that but yeah
it's true it's look this is all new for
all of us and even the ways that we
approach in and and the you know kind of
the rules and and and you're constantly
spending your day kind of going okay now
what am I not only what am I gonna do
today well how am I gonna try to keep
myself safe today
it's it's um you know it's a learning
curve for sure I mean I remembered it
seems like just yesterday that you know
we were kind of like well don't do watch
our hands we're good yes that's right no
things have changed change big time
you're not meant for captivity but we
were finding a way to live with it at
the moment Kevin Bacon thank you very
much for being here great idea thank you
Kevin thanks for having me folks